Do you know who this is?
It's Selena Gomez.
My name is Selena.
The one that you hear the songs of?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
[SCREAMING]
She's my dramatic one.
Well, that was me.
Come here, boo butt.
No.
Yeah, you're awesome.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, she's real.
Mommy went to school with her.
She lived right down the street from me.
Mommy grew up with her.
Can I have a hug?
Does that make you happy?
Yes.
Well, thank you.
I appreciate it.
It was good seeing you.
I'm glad everything's good with you and went better.
Trust me, it was real scary at that point.
I grew up with you, I knew it.
So to see you go through that [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah.
Thank you.
I do feel good.
Oh, we love y'all.
OK, bye.
Say, bye.
Say, thank you.